so oxytocin does a lot of things in our
body it makes us feel connected so when
we're making eye contact with people
when we hand shake we touch we have
moments we're like oh you do that yes i
do that too
that all produces this chemical that
makes us feel the warm and fuzzies they
found that if people do nose sprays of
oxygen like
they will participate collaborate and
give away more money in prisoner's
dilemma game oh my god there's there's a
whole market for this now
the other thing that we're looking for
is dopamine the chemical of pleasure
it's also the chemical of motivation
when we feel excited about something we
want to learn more this is why when i
answer a question that i haven't
answered before it actually gives myself
dopamine right like i get to share a
story i haven't shared so my secret push
for asking non-socially scripted
questions the secret reason i'm doing
that is not only because you might find
out something it's also to wake them up
that they might get to talk about
something that gets them a little bit
excited and that in a weird way makes
you more memorable
hello welcome to the pretty intense
podcast thank you very much for
listening i really appreciate you as a
listener and this is such important work
to me and so by subscribing and liking
and commenting
you're telling me that you really like
what you what you're hearing so to get
into it today we have vanessa van
edwards she is an author uh she's a
behavioral investigator that drives her
books so her first book was called
captivate her latest book is cues where
she unpacks 96 cues that we have that we
signal with our bodies both there's four
categories verbal nonverbal vocal and
imagery anyway fascinating stuff so we
talked all about
just how we interact with people and the
things that we're picking up and you
know what what we can do to be able to
just decipher whether someone is
trustworthy whether someone is faking it
taking advantage of us all of the
different things that we're dealing with
what's charismatic
those human interactions that play such
a big role uh in fact probably play
i'm going to say a significantly bigger
role than you even realize in your life
and so the ability to be able to not
only decipher them but also to be able
to
cue yourself
and to you know whether you want to
relax or whether you want to get amped
up or whether you want to be more in
charge be calmer all of those things you
can cue yourself too so this is super
deep powerful work and uh vanessa is a
really cool character and she has some
also funny stories to tell you so can't
wait for you to listen please hit
subscribe if you like this please send
your friends if you like it too
and you want to share with them this is
good information for for everyone to
hear
and leave a comment let me know what
you're thinking in the meantime enjoy
this episode i just circled in like
heavy pen
the quote in uh the paragraph in your
first book captivate i haven't read cues
yet but we're going to talk about that
yeah
about the death of small talk i was like
yes please everybody death of small talk
did we make small talk here at the
beginning or was that not small no
no we we jumped right in actually i
think that i would always rather jump to
level two and this is i forgive me i'm
gonna bring up research in the first few
minutes i can't help it you should add
that i love it bring it okay okay so
this research sort of saved my life and
by life i mean my conversation which is
that the research has found that there
are three levels of intimacy we're
connecting with people and level one is
the area we're most comfortable with
it's called general traits
this is why at the beginning of every
interaction we're like how are you what
do you do where are you from
and so that level one we like to know
those basic things about each other
level two is where i get excited it's
called personal concerns motivations
values worries what drives you what gets
you up in the morning
so level two i find that if you can jump
into level two you actually skip all
that level one autopilot and so we got
to talk right into i i accidentally not
even on purpose shared a funny story
about going to costco vulnerability
which was actually level two
and so we got kind of bonding and
talking by the way level three which is
like whoa it's like we're really
bothered it's called uh self narrative
which are the stories you tell yourself
about yourself
level three is so intimate and so
special that we don't even get to it
with most people in our lives but once
you know the story that someone tells
themselves about themselves you can
understand their behavior so my goal in
every interaction hopefully today we can
just jump right to level two and three
is
what drives our behavior what drives our
communication
hmm that's fascinating well
you saying all of those things makes me
really curious what the because i love
the way you are able to unpack people
and i i even when we were emailing a
little before i'm like what does she
know about me already by my emails
so much but you talk about jumping
straight into level two and sometimes
when i start an interview and i'm
curious what this means about me um
i they don't even know i've started
because i i like to sort of i call it
like soft start you know i just
basically talk about something that
doesn't feel like today on the show we
have vanessa van edwards she's uh you
know i don't do that i jump right into i
i basically transition the conversa i
transition into a conversation with
something that they just mentioned so
that it's not some sort of like because
i feel like it puts people on guard more
and i like them to be more relaxed and
so i lead in really soft and people
sometimes don't even know we've started
what does that say about me
it says so much and it says that i think
and tell me if this is right that you
have an allergy to level one
so
right so like i small talk like it gives
me hives like i really don't i feel
uncomfortable in that level one because
i i can tell we're on small talk and so
you have this very interesting tactic
which i love which is that you you know
that if you ask the socially scripted
questions people will stay on social
script yeah and this is the biggest
problem i think with our video calls and
our intros is we feel that we have to
start with hey good to meet you i'm
vanessa how are you we're in a podcast
okay now we have vanessa and edwards on
the show which literally tells the
person's brain let's start on autopilot
and then and i think you must know this
as an interviewer it's really hard to
break them
yeah it takes a long time it takes quite
a while i mean it could take 20-30
minutes before they get out of that zone
who's got that time right exactly we've
got an hour we got to go there
so and also i think and for people
listening
there's actually some very easy swaps we
can do it's it's really just breaking a
brain pattern so a brain pattern that we
have is we meet someone we say how are
you good how are you been busy busy yeah
it's been busy but good right like i
feel like every answer right now is this
right how are you
oh busy busy busy good but busy
exactly
it's like a script so what you can do is
just slightly tweak it and you don't
want to jump right into too deep this is
a big mistake that i think people who
are allergic to level one make the
mistake they make is they jump to level
three
that's too much right like especially
for my my lovely introverts my recovery
aqua people it's too much so the worst
thing you can do is be like so what's
your greatest fear
what keeps you up at night right like
that's like too much too fast but what
you can do is little swaps so for
example one of my favorites is so what's
been
good totally it's a it's a little
different because it's not how are you
and you'll see people will go oh oh
what's been good um yeah you know what i
my dad's in town or whatever it is so
what's been good um instead of working
on anything or you've been busy or what
do you do you can say doing anything
exciting recently or working on anything
exciting recently and then this is my
ultimate hack for my lazy folks
i'm a lazy poke so here's my lazy vote
okay
monday and tuesday default to do
anything fun this past weekend
thursday friday default too
have any fun plans for the weekend right
now
wednesday just don't talk to anyone
easy just skip it hump day nobody talks
to anybody on hump day just like get
through it's like extra coffee
you know like i can't talk to you i
don't have a conversation starter for
today i'm so sorry it's wednesday i just
can't
what does it say about people
that start at level one and like really
are comfortable with level one like
we've established we're allergic to it
it's it drains me to no end it drains me
i feel literally my life force energy
just depleting it's like it's like my
phone is on and every app is open and
it's just
yeah yes that is okay so let's talk
about each level so for people who love
level one
these are often but not always my
introverts these are folks who have
dipped their toe into level two and been
judged
or been rejected
or they're ashamed of their level two
and so it's actually very important to
respect people where they are and to
safely and lovingly carry them up to
level two if that's where you want to be
so with level one my people who love
level one you know these people these
are my jokers or my folks who literally
will not go past one or two word answers
right so you're like so what do you do
i'm marketing
yeah well what got you into it my dad
and um how long you doing five to ten
years lately
and also and they won't ask you back
questions you know those people yes oh
oh the worst i mean like i could
literally be on question 12 and then i
finally realized i'm on question 12 and
i go
all right i think i need to exit
you're like and bye
oh my gosh i have diarrhea i have to go
that's a good one i like that one um or
just um i will sometimes just like look
around the room and be like oh i see
someone by um
even when i'm alone it works really well
actually so for my level one people i
want so if you've asked three or four
questions in a row and they're not
asking questions back or they're
answering really i would say almost
tight
hiding answers
i want you to recognize that this is
someone who has felt like they've had to
go into hiding
and that's because i think awkwardness
dresses up as different things right i
joke that i'm a recovering awkward
person
some people when they're awkward or
they're scared they hide they close in
they talk less they don't want to be
noticed other people and their
awkwardness do the opposite you might
know these people too other people they
they get big they get dramatic they get
loud
they interrupt people they the life of
the party almost not in a good way
so this if you've t if you're into
someone who's level one the best thing
you can do is show them that level two
is safe but that means you have to go
first okay
and this is a sort of beautiful
challenge of you're with someone and
they're giving you one or two whatever
answers
what if you dip your toe into level two
so it's a very safe way to do this is to
think about um what are your motivations
what are your goals
what drives you
so for example you could maybe say well
and i was just talking to another day
where she she said that she's in a pivot
so she i said so you know working on
anything exciting these days right so
not what do you do i didn't know what
she did right she said you know
and i saw her like take a moment she
goes
i'm a teacher
but i could hear yeah i could like hear
and i said a teacher
is that excited about that what's with
what's there right she said no
i i'm thinking about maybe doing
something different i've been
moonlighting a little with a little
craft shop on etsy
oh that's exciting okay right
so that gave a window of a little bit of
vulnerability a little bit of level two
and that you have a choice then to honor
it and get excited for her or go into
vulnerability yourself
so talking about some part of your
history that surprises you or has been
different i'm talking about a vulnerable
part of your story um going into um a
motivation or a wish that you've been
wanting or thinking about i think that
when we do that we give people
permission to go to level two with us
so would you do that after they said
that or would you you or you go first
and say something like you know i used
to be a mermaid for hire in high school
to make money someone may have done that
in the past i don't know who that would
be and then then sort of opens the door
for someone else or would you
after they say something sort of
vulnerable and open and like go in go
that direction would you then
then sort of chime in about yourself
because i get
yeah which one would you do
so i would do the one that makes you
most excited right so if you're like
whoa i'm super into that like etsy
awesome die deep if you're like oh that
reminds me of one of my own stories and
that gets me excited to share that
that's like a way of following our
authenticity in a very subtle way so
let's take mine for example
we've got we got to do it if you
mentioned mermaid so
for everyone listening danica was like
do you have any weird interests like
woodworking or wine or and i was like
we're interested i and i asked my
husband who sit next to me i said do i
have any weird interests and he's like
no i think you're pretty basic i was
like hey
hey
hey i was like i like to read to hike
and then i remembered so back in the day
and i will share this sometimes the
level two story is i people will always
ask me a very socially scripted question
how did you start doing what you're
doing right
that is actually a socially scripted
question that i don't love because we've
answered it a million times before of
course
some people ask me how many times you've
answered that i can't even imagine oh
hundreds thousands and so i will now do
a little bit i surprise them a little
bit instead of giving my chronology so
one of the answers i might give if i'm
feeling excited is well i've always been
interested in alternative sources of
income
for example when i was in high school
the only so back in high school i was
looking for i was always had the
entrepreneurial itch and i someone told
me that i had mermaid hair which i was
the biggest compliment someone could
have given me and she's like you should
just like see if you can be a mermaid at
like parties
i was like okay i was a lifeguard at the
time so i put out a little poster in my
neighborhood that said
lifeguarding
mermaiding for hire
and people would hire me i'd wear one of
those like tails in the pool and i would
lifeguard and i would pretend to be a
mermaid and cover myself in glitter and
i got paid like a hundred bucks for that
and back in the day that was a lot of
money
yeah
yeah
it was once
10 years ago
um
that's so fast well thank you for
sharing your vulnerable story i probably
should have checked whether or not you
wanted to share that
i guess you could you could have avoided
that but i thought you probably know
that this question means i'm looking for
some anecdotal sort of
things about you that we could bring up
that would be interesting so
that was definitely interesting also i
wanted to talk about something different
you know a lot of the times in my
interviews i do a lot of interviews i'm
very grateful to get those opportunities
but typically i get asked the same
questions and i've never brought up my
mermaid story and so that was kind of
fun to talk about for me and remember
let's talk about from a chemical
perspective so when we're interacting
with people there are three basic
chemicals that we're interested in and i
would promise i'll keep the science
lesson brief just just for us to
understand
the first one that we're looking for is
oxytocin so oxytocin does a lot of
things in our body but very basically it
makes us feel connected so when we're
making eye contact with people when we
hand shake we touch we have me too
moments we have moments where like oh
you do that yes i do that too
that all produces this chemical that
makes us feel warm and fuzzies and
literally they've proven this they've
synthesized oxytocin they found that if
people do nose sprays voxios like
those sprays
they will participate collaborate and
give away more money in prisoner's
dilemma games oh my god there's there's
a whole market for this
now no spray on the way into a charity
event i'm i'm a little terrified like
that's gonna happen like i always wonder
sometimes if like i smell something
weird in a hotel if they're like pumping
oxytocin into the room so oxytocin so
oxytocin is like that's why
in some of those moments and we're
talking about like welcoming people
having me too saying yes yes i have that
too the other thing that we're looking
for is dopamine so dopamine is very
simplified the chemical of pleasure
more than just pleasure it's also the
chemical of motivation
when we feel excited about something we
want to learn more this is why when i
answer a question that i haven't
answered before it actually gives myself
dopamine right like i get to share a
story i haven't shared so my secret push
for asking non-socially scripted
questions the secret reason i'm doing
that is not only because you might find
out something it's also to wake them up
that they might get to talk about
something that gets them a little bit
excited and that in a weird way makes
you more memorable right like it it
actually makes you like oh she asked me
good questions i want to spend more time
with her
yeah yeah yeah as i prep for all my
interviews i
you know read your book but also i watch
interviews too and i heard that one of
your your life goal is to with tom
bilyeu and funny enough i interviewed
lisa after this so um
oh yeah you gotta give her a big cuddle
for me
i know i'll have to
do it from a zoom distance but um but uh
anyway she at the end of that or i think
it was at the end of tom's you said that
your life goal was to wake people up
and i was like
we share the same life goal i don't
think that we we share exactly how we're
going to accomplish it but that is at
the core my life goal is to just wake
people up so when you said that what do
you mean by that
um by the way i think that i love that
you're approaching the same goal in a
different way because your talents are
different than my talents
right like like if we were both doing it
the same way that wouldn't help as many
people but you're going to help
different people and more people by
approaching a different way
so for me for me i think that um
the only way that we can feel empathy
the only way that we can feel compassion
the only way that we can feel less
loneliness i am very worried about
loneliness i think it's something that
i'm
i think we're becoming increasingly more
lonely
the only way that we can fight that
in a non-chemical way like not without
drugs is by knowing how to stay awake
having conversations that fuel us having
relationships that feel really um
supportive and incredible and giving
waking up and knowing that we can stay
off of autopilot and we're going to be
accepted for it
there's actually some really interesting
studies about ambivalence
so i used to have a lot of writing where
i write about toxic people difficult
people and that's a fascinating set of
science right how do we create
boundaries around difficult people how
do we create um walls and and say no to
difficult or toxic people
but actually what's more insidious are
ambivalent relationships so ambivalence
is are those relationships where
you could take it or leave it
you kind of like them but you're not
sure if they like you or you're not sure
if you like them
you never feel particularly charged when
you leave them you see them on your
calendar or you get a text from them and
you're not like lighting up
ambivalence is actually the sort of in
between okay what they found is that
they looked at police officers and they
asked them about their relationships
and their prediction was that
police officers who had difficult
personalities in their workplace would
have the least work happiness
but actually what they found is that
that was not the case that police
officers who worked with difficult
people knew they were difficult they
avoided them they didn't invite them to
lunch
they tried to not talk to them actually
it was quite easy for them to be like
that's not my person
the police officers who had the lowest
rate of work happiness were the ones who
had the most ambivalent relationship
these were people they worked with where
they weren't sure do they really support
me these are those people where you sit
with them and they make a comment and
you wonder was that passive aggressive
what was that supportive or you shared
good news and you're not really sure if
they're happy for you
those relationships are so draining and
when we are asleep when we are on
autopilot we don't get rid of them we
don't level them up we don't get them
out of our lives and so that ambivalence
i don't want you to have any
relationships or conversations where
you're feeling like you're half asleep
so i think that that's that's my reason
for it what's your reason for it
oh well thank you for asking um mine is
to
uh
wake people up to the
true power that they have within them
and
uh
how
they
their perception is reality and that
they're really in control of their
destiny and um
i know perception is something that i
keyed up on one thing that you had
mentioned at some point you said that um
i think it was the only difference
between um the only difference between
anxiety and excitement is a mindset
which to me feels very much like
perception
so just to wake people up to
perhaps other realities going on in the
world to just get people to question
things it doesn't mean that you'll
change your opinion it might still stand
true but also it gives an opportunity to
um
to grow because you can't grow if you
don't learn anything new or
change and evolve and grow so yeah being
able to evolve and grow requires you to
be able to be open-minded and so by
waking people up
they kind of are able to evolve and grow
which i think is what we're here to do i
think we're here to evolve and grow oh i
love it so what's interesting is that i
think that we're talking a little bit
both of us are talking about sort of
giving names to our unconscious needs
desires and opinions right like making
them conscious like being awake to them
yeah and one of the things that i found
very empowering that got me out of a lot
of my anxiety and my imposter syndrome
was understanding that there is a hidden
language that we're all speaking
right that we are constantly sending
cues back and forth and we are
incredibly contagious
so
what research has found is that when we
are around someone who is afraid we will
actually catch their fear without
realizing it
so this is another reason why i think
the weight is so important so this is a
really gross study i talked about this
in my ted talk it's very gross but i
promise it's worth it so here's what
they did okay they
uh brought people to the lab and they
split them up into two groups
the first group they had them run on the
treadmill wearing sweat pads so uh pads
that would catch their sweat while they
ran
and run the treadmill get really really
sweaty they took those sweatpads the
second group they said we're gonna take
you skydiving for the first time and
they had them wear the same
new set of sweatpads and they took them
up an airplane they pushed them out of
an airplane and they had people
this is new people yeah new people yeah
so people first time skydivers had to go
up where these flat pads and they were
sweating fear sweat right like imagine
what you feel right before jumping on an
airplane i did yeah oh my gosh okay yeah
so that's what okay
they took these sweatpads and they asked
unsuspecting new participants to smell
them
this is where kids grows
now imagine i know it's like it's real
nasty
these participants had no idea what they
were smelling they literally just
okay
and then they it's like here i think
this milk is off will you just tell can
you tell me if this milk is off or like
when someone said this smells horrible
smell this really yeah i want this
okay so there's they smell both these
peas and they put them in a brain
scanner they found when participants
smelled the sky-diving sweatpads their
own fear center their own amygdala began
to light light up
began to activate in other words when we
smell fear sweat even though we do have
no idea that it's fear sweat we begin to
feel afraid
this study has so many implications
because it shows that there is this
language that's happening with us even
on a chemical level it didn't even see
the person that we are constantly
picking up on each other's signals
and i think when we are awake when we
are
ready for those signals we know they are
affecting us we can take control of them
sure
the study that totally changed my life
so i knew that cues were contagious but
i wasn't quite sure how was that when we
see negative cues we catch them and our
body actually changes
so this happens not only from a chemical
perspective from a nonverbal perspective
very simple they had participants come
into a room and they found that when
someone spotted a cue of social
rejection so acute social rejection
could be an eye roll
it could be a scoff
it could be a negative tone of voice
yeah great idea right yeah
when we spot that
our own field of vision increases
literally our pupils dilate to see more
and this is our body's way of going uh
oh is there another key that's being
sent to us what's my escape route
and so i think that my other aspect of
being awake is knowing that these cues
are being sent to you being aware enough
to label them take control of them and
then respond with confidence
that that cycle is the most empowering
thing we can do i've never thought about
that it's a fascinating study to be able
to like do it off of smell
um
gross but totally interesting
what about
what about energy and frequency like
what about
what about that when you can't smell
them but someone walks into the room and
you can just feel them there's this is
where it's really hard to parse out
energy
versus cues versus scent and we'll take
video for example all right let's just
look at video right video i cannot smell
you danika you look like you smell
really good but i don't know right i
just have to guess right smell amazing
okay that's what i thought so
we take smell out of the equation where
we take some out of the equation
i am looking at a couple of different
modes that you are transmitting things
to me so because we've removed smell
because we've removed touch right we
can't touch we can't shake hands we
can't give a hug
we are focusing on words so verbal vocal
and non-verbal
and so i think that when we talk about
energy what we're actually talking about
is how we are transmitting signals with
those three modes so the first one is
words obviously the first few words we
say the second one is gestures posture
facial expressions and the last one is
our vocal so how we say our words sure
what research has found is about sixty
to ninety percent of our communication
is actually just in the non-verbal
category so we say energy i think when
someone walks into a room we are taking
in their gait like how they're walking
through the room we're taking in how
they wear their clothing we're taking in
how they say hello here's a really
specific example
when we are anxious when we are nervous
we are afraid let's take those those
skydivers right i guarantee you if you
were to ask those skydivers right before
they jumped out of a plane to say hello
to answer their phone hello
when we are anxious or afraid our vocal
cords tense and i'm gonna do it for you
right now so you can hear so right now
my vocal cords are relaxed because i'm
having a good time we're chatting but if
i were to go into anxiety and i tighten
my vocal cords you can actually hear
that i go a little higher on my vocal
pitch and also i get a little bit more
vocal fry so my vocal chords are tight
it's very very hard to get out of fry so
i talk higher and also you can hear it
and the more i tighten my vocal cords
the harder it is for me to get any kind
of resonance so what happens is when
people are really anxious they'll say
hey
hello
and we can hear it yeah it's like the
ready-to-cry sort of sound too
oh yes actually it's a very good point
yes it's exactly what we sound like best
way me when i'm about to cry
so we're listening
right without even realizing it too when
someone walks in the room or hops on
video and says hey guys
or let's take it down a notch this is
the most anxious hey guys
okay that's the most anxious yeah and
the next level which i hear very often
is someone answers at the top of their
breath
and this is because they've been holding
their breath the whole time they're a
little bit nervous they go hey
yeah
totally hello
yeah and we're at this we're talking
about we are accidentally signaling um
anxiety versus now i'm gonna do the
opposites so what happens when i relax
my vocal cords and by the way you can
try this with me so hopefully you can
try this at home if you don't if you
don't mind this is a really helpful
exercise so what i want you to do danica
if you're willing is yeah i want to take
a deep breath and i want you to say
hello at the top of your breath so hello
hello
there you go
way higher versus so now i want you to
take a deep breath and i want you to say
hello on the out breath it's going to
sound like this
hello
hello
right yeah totally totally different so
if you try that i want you to ask
yourself
what voice are you using
when you're
on video calls presenting talking to
your partner talking to your kids in an
interview are you up here
hey everyone it's so good to see you
or you down here
that is the that's energy i think we're
talking about energy
we can literally hear it totally what's
the exhale hello
conveying because obviously you said
anxiety at the top is it conveying
confidence or is it just relaxed is it
power
okay so this is oh this is a tricky
question i'm going to answer it with
another study because i can't help it
which is
our vote our vocal cords are very tied
to the rest of our body our breath our
chest the space we're taking up so one
study university of british columbia
found that winning athletes when they
win a race they take up as much space as
possible so they expand their chest they
tilt their head towards the sky they
expand their arms they often jump up and
down yeah when we take up space it
literally relax our vocal cords it
allows us to take in more breath so it
could be
pride it could be confidence it could be
relaxation so when i'm at the lowest end
by the way if i just i'm going to
scrunch my shoulders up and i'm going to
tighten my jaw and i'm going to go like
a defeated athlete a defeated athlete
typically tuck search into their chest
no matter how relaxed the local parts
are it's still really really hard to
give you my full vocal power like you
can literally hear it
so the moment i maximize my my space the
lower my shoulders i tilt my head up i
expand my chest you can hear it in my
voice
there are hundreds of these vocal cues
that we're listening for and so that
energy that we pick up from someone we
go
it's because we are listening for
anxiety and we don't want to catch it
we don't want to listen to someone buy
from someone be with someone date
someone love someone trust someone if
they're anxious so can we cue ourselves
like as you're saying all these things
it seems like okay they'll you know
they'll say like it's your stress just
take a deep breath or whatever so like
can we if we know we get some social
anxiety do we arrive at the situation
just kind of go
hi you know like whether you're starting
a call or whether you're going to meet
someone or walk into a meeting or a job
interview can you cue yourself and what
are some of the one of those things that
you can do to cue yourself because first
off there are you just to like
give more information for cues your new
book there are four different categories
of the cues and maybe you could say
those and then um and then go into what
we can do to like feel more relaxed and
feel more confident
yes so you just
said it perfectly which is i think we
must cue ourselves we have to cue
ourselves and we don't realize that we
are constantly curing ourselves when we
are asleep i think we don't realize how
often we are setting ourselves up for
failure or success
right so part of this is understanding
the cues you're saying to yourself i
love it when people say oh take a deep
breath or pause for a second because the
secret benefit of that the reason why we
like to take a deep breath or
we try to relax our body secretly that
also makes us sound better so here's a
couple things that you can think about
to actually cue yourself for confidence
to cue yourself for feeling like your
most confident self so the first one is
um try to maximize the distance this is
a really weird one it's a really weird
one i want you to maximize the distance
between your earlobe and your shoulder
oh yeah sure okay i know that sounds so
weird but what i often see on video is
people hike up their shoulders and they
tilt down their head and they go hey
good to see you
yeah
and they do that because when we're a
little nervous a little anxious we try
to take up as little space as possible
that study i mentioned with the athletes
losing athletes want to take up as
little space as possible why
they don't want to be noticed we're in
shame or defeat we want less people to
see us so we tilt our head in we crunch
in our shoulders and we're trying to
protect our vulnerable organs we tilt
our chin down to protect our jugular we
cross our arms or put our arms tightly
to our chest to protect our heart and
our gut
so we do that instinctively and what can
happen is
we're getting ready for a meeting or a
video call and what are we doing
checking our email
so we have our literally checking our
email or checking our phone is the exact
position of the feet
by accident right
our our shoulders are tucked our chin is
tucked our arms are to our sides we're
blocking
and some people wonder why they're
making bad first impressions or why they
feel so awkward at the start of video
calls because accidentally
like this and then hello and they pop up
and brought and broadened
so the first thing is i want you to
maximize especially in the first few
seconds of interaction the few first few
seconds before an interaction maximize
difference in your ear and your shoulder
just that alone it's going to open up
your chest it's going to make your head
go high it will help relax your vocal
cords
second i love a deep breath no
hyperventilating i don't want you i
don't want too much right and we also
have to be very careful to not be
elizabeth holmes
so elizabeth holmes
theranos if you've watched that amazing
documentary elizabeth holmes i think
maybe read this study back in the day
which says the lower your voice tone the
more confident you're gonna sound and so
she made her voice like this and she
ended up talking like this which sounded
totally fake so this is the lowest
i know it's crazy this is the lowest end
of your natural voice this doesn't
matter if you're male or female that the
lower end of our natural voice does best
so breath expansion lowest voice can you
fake it i'm really wondering this
because in this world today there's so
many manipulators
narcissists
um
gaslighters
there's just so many people trying to
take advantage of you
and and we get duped like i mean i've
been duped in my life with people and
i'm like man i feel like i'm usually a
pretty good judge of character and i can
feel their energy or get their pick up
maybe more cues than other people but
i've been there before so can you fake
it and does it take like a sociopathic
personality perhaps that actually
believes in their bs
to be the faker like how do we decipher
in that world what can we how do we how
do we not get taken advantage of
so i have been there too i've been taken
i've been taken this is why i started
this research i never
i never thought this would be a book i
did it because i got duped
i got duped and i said never again
never never again what happened if
you're willing to share
yes so
this so i started this research 17 years
ago if you can believe it this was the
height of my awkward stage
where um i really trusted someone i
thought again i thought it was a pretty
good judge of character i had felt good
vibes and good energy
however
there were red flags that i ignored
i had little hints about this person
that i was like uh
you
yeah kind of like oh well or oh yeah oh
what i'm sure that was fine yeah yeah he
was having a bad day yeah i had a person
that i really thought was great and i
and as time went on i kept ignoring the
red flags i kept ignoring the red flags
and of course i ended up it ended up
that he was completely lying to me that
um so many of the things he had told me
were completely false or had a tiny
kernel of truth
and i gave him a couple of months of
very
what i what i gave him my most
intimate friendship and
i
totally
was
lied to like 100 percent lying too i'm
sorry
and that was a moment where i realized i
want to be able to trust my intuition
but i want to know that my intuition is
accurate and so the first answer to
question this is this was my biggest
fear with writing this book a lot of the
research i was using for me personally
right like i was using it as my own
system there are 96 used in the book and
i wanted to be competent in fluent age
96 so i could spot them when i saw them
and i could send the right cues myself
the problem is you can fake it
right people can these cues work
they can work so my biggest worry with
this book is that people would use this
for evil and not good
they would use the powers in a bad way
the only positive thing is
it is exhausting
it is really hard in the short term i
think we can do it right any cue can be
faked in the short term but in the long
term
one it's exhausting and authentic and
second as humans i i have those little
red flags that i ignored so in the long
term it's impossible to keep it up and
thank goodness the research backs us up
as well so there was one study that very
basically looked at fake happiness and
real happiness right this is the most
important one right if we have to above
all the cues we have to know i want to
know to spot real authentic happiness
versus fake happiness right very simply
they found that they showed people to dr
barbara wilde she showed people pictures
with a real smile and a fake smile so by
the way these are really hard to
distinguish just from the naked eye so
real smile reaches all the way up into
our crow's feet our upper cheek muscles
are activated right all the way up here
you want to feel it you can put a pencil
between your teeth and try to not let
your lips touch like oh no i can hear
your eyes all the way up into your eyes
when those upward cheek muscles are
engaged
that is real happiness
anyone can fake smile this is when the
smile stays at the bottom half of the
face and then those cheek muscles are
activated it's actually very hard to
tell this from the naked eye so they
show people pictures of real and fake
smiles they found that when they gave
mood tests to participants before and
after
people who saw the real smile caught the
good mood they literally answered more
positively in their second mood survey
people who saw the fake happiness had no
mood change at all
in other words
we are picking up on these cues and when
they are inauthentic people have less of
an impact on us when we see fake
happiness or fake anger or fake sadness
somehow our body our gut our intuition
knows that we shouldn't be as impacted
or affected by that person
so yes we can fake it but it will not
last the long term and so the most
important thing here is first cueing
yourself right getting yourself in that
right mindset before you begin to cue
someone else how can we tell if someone
when someone is trustworthy or not
okay so let's talk about um what i call
red flags so these are cues specifically
that
aren't so great that in when we look at
the research
liars typically show them so we did a
really fun research experiment in our
lab where we had people play two truths
and a lie so we ask them to submit if
you've ever played this game it's such a
fun game
someone says two true statements and one
lie and you try to guess which is the
lie so we had participants send in two
truths and a lie and we coded them we
wanted to see was there differences in
the lying answers and there were
patterns things that people did much
more often on the lying statements and
the true statements so those are our red
flags there are things that our bodies
tend to do in shame deceit guilt and
fear so i'll go through a couple these
are the ones that i want you to kind of
keep in your back pocket of hmm
that was a little odd
why do they do that so the first one is
actually a vocal cue and it's the
question inflection so the question
inflections when we go up at the end of
our sentence so when we're saying
something it sounds like we're asking a
question
so our everybody in england is a liar
then because everyone in england can
flex up and ask a question
and my kiwis i've had i've had new
zealanders say oh i tend to go up at the
end of my sentence this is actually
really important to know about yourself
and if this is part of your your lexicon
or your lingual patterns it's really
important to know because
on the important statements it's
important you say it state it don't ask
it
the reason for that is because our brain
knows that when the question inflection
is used we're asking for permission or
we're asking if things are okay so what
they've found is that when participants
are in a brain scanner and they hear the
question reflection mistakenly use an
honest use on a statement
they go from listening to scrutinizing
literally our brain knows wait a minute
why was it what why did they ask that
so in the two truths in a lie they
sounded like this see if you can guess
annika which is my lie you ready
i was born in los angeles
i love dogs i'm a vegetarian
right not a vegetarian
we heard this on
hundreds of these lies so the other
thing that happens is that liars often
ask their lies because they're asking do
you believe me
does that sound true
so literally their brain gives them away
so the very first thing is
one if you were saying something
important make sure you state it i do a
lot of sales trainings and this is the
number one mistake i hear on prices
okay they'll be like on a roll they're
like we'd love to have your business we
love to work with you and the price of
the service is five thousand dollars
when you ask your numbers ask your terms
ask your worth you are begging people to
negotiate with you yeah you are begging
you're saying i don't really believe
this number and you should question it
too second is if you are hearing someone
answer a very important question and
they go up at the end of their sentence
red flag
it doesn't necessarily mean someone's
lying but it means i need to do more
research so let's talk about one in
dating right so you ask you know um so
how do you feel about your ex
not really sure
yeah right right oh you know um we have
a good relationship and um it's been
it's been really great and we we talk
all the time
right like
that vocal pattern
is something is off there right like the
words are saying something the vocals is
something here so question selection is
one red flag to watch out for and it's
very hard to fake that so if you are
actually lying it's really hard to get
rid of the question of collection
interestingly because it can be positive
or negative and it's a lip purse so this
was the research that kind of kicked me
off so i had just gone through this
horrible friendship breakup with this
person who had lied to me and i felt so
i the crazy thing is when someone takes
advantage of you
when someone lies to you you feel wrong
right like i felt so
stupid and so
dirty in a weird way even though this
other person had lied to me so i've just
gone through this friendship breakup and
um
i was watching this in 2005 i was
watching
larry king on lance armstrong sorry
larry king live interviewing lance
armstrong
i'm trying to online yes okay and uh
larry king was asking lance armstrong
have you ever doped
which spoiler alert we know that lance
armstrong has doped well in 2005 he was
insisting that he never had so
larry king asked him have you ever doped
and lauren's last run says a bold face
lie i have never doped
and then he presses his lips into a hard
line
and a lip purse where his his lips
disappeared and he pressed his mouth
together
and i remember watching it going what
was that my spidey sense my intuition
was like no way
no way right so like me my gut was like
something's wrong here and then i saw
that lip person i wondered what was that
so i began to look at the research i
didn't even have the name for it at the
time and i found this is a withholding
queue
the nonverbal research when someone is
trying to keep something in
hold back keep it together they'll lip
purse purses have to say don't give
yourself away
don't say too much
zip that lip zip is literally yes zip
that lip like
and so
i i was like wow what an interesting cue
so i began to watch for it and i noticed
that when people are in deep shame
sometimes deception
really don't want to talk about
something they will let purse without
even realizing it so the one to watch
out for again it doesn't always mean a
lie but it means there is something more
going on that someone is trying to just
hold in hold it back
the best thing in this one is to give
someone permission right if i see a lit
person i'll say are we all good
this all makes sense
you have any other questions for me
anything else we haven't covered it's
totally fine if we go a little deeper
so
the way we respond to cues is just as
important as spotting it right so you
spot it it goes in the mental bank of
notes and then it's how can i let this
person feel more comfortable so they can
actually open up to me i think that's
how we get out of that fake
um
people trying to fake they make it we
give them permission to tell us the
truth even if it's hard
right
what about eye contact what does that
say
okay so eye contact is a beautiful cue
and it's actually our our
hum the way that humans connect is we
think okay if i'm with someone and i'm
making eye contact with them i'm
literally close enough to make eye
contact this person's probably the
friend not fo and we should connect
so a really interesting chemical thing
happens in our bodies the moment we make
eye contact so when we make eye contact
our bodies produce oxytocin that
chemical i mentioned a couple minutes
ago
again oxytocin is so critical for our
connections
have you have you ever been danica this
is a question for you have you ever been
with someone who literally won't make
eye contact with you
at times sure oh my goodness okay so
there's a reason why fubbing you know
when someone looks at their phone and
they're like snubbing you there's a
reason why it like
like it drives crazy oh yeah it always
happened before it's like are you
listening
at all
are you are you here are you deaf or
worse
overhead gazing where someone is like
looking around the party or the room to
see if there's anyone better to talk to
oh you got to be really careful that you
don't you don't
you can't be distracted when you're
talking to people because all it says is
i don't want to be here
okay there you go so what's interesting
about this there's actually something
chemical going on so when someone fubs
you is that the right way to use that
word
okay if someone's [ __ ] you um or if
someone's overhead gazing you or you
have someone who just won't make eye
contact they're looking off to the side
the reason it irks you is because your
body is saying where is my oxytocin
we want oxytocin it is incredibly
important for our ability to connect and
so when we're not getting eye contact
our body chemically cannot catch up and
so our bodies going i'm with this person
and i'm not getting a chemical i need to
connect
this is one of the reasons why we're so
we you know you hear love addicts for
people who are addicted to love
love gives us oxytocin like that that
deep gazing into someone's eyes all the
cuddles all the kissing that's a lot of
oxytocin so when we're with someone and
we're not getting even a little bit
through eye contact our body starts to
revolt and the longer someone fubs us or
doesn't give us eye contact the more we
feel disconnected and disengaged and
then this is why it's taught yes this is
why someone you know you'll be with
people and you're like i just couldn't
click with them i just like didn't feel
it yeah it's probably because there
wasn't enough oxytocin
wow
oh i have to make a special note
especially no special note which is i
love eye contact right i kind of just
wonderful produced oxytocin however
there is such a thing as too much eye
contact
so have you ever been with someone where
they're like boring into your eyes
you're like okay i got it a little yeah
there i mean i probably am one of those
people that border on that because
i really like to like i am gazing into
your eyes vanessa i know that we have to
go through a camera lens and through
that but i am
um
maybe you're feeling the energetics of
that
um but uh but i i probably borderline on
too much
just because it's i'm trying to connect
right
so it's trying to make sure they think
and they can tell i'm listening
for sure and as an interviewer that's
incredibly important an interview is not
the same as a typical conversation right
so in an interview for you as the
interviewer to make 90 to 100 eye
contact is amazing because you're saying
i can't participate as much verbally
like if tannic and i were in a regular
conversation we would be taking turns i
was like
i would be i would be asking you
questions you asked any questions i had
to learn that one the hard way but yeah
okay i used to do more of that when i
interviewed
okay okay yes okay so now i do this
are you not and i feel your eye contact
so as an interviewer it's it's
your way of making up for you're not
talking and that's and that feels good
to me in a normal conversation
we are looking for about 60 of the time
eye contact and that's that's a
statistic specifically for western
culture which is a little bit different
if you're out of western cultures
but why this is important is because in
a back-to-back conversation it's okay to
think about something and look away
to process oh what was his name and
close your eyes and look down yeah where
and so don't feel pressured
that you cannot break eye contact
because that that pressure actually
feels almost territorial in the
interview it's great but in a back to
back conversation not and the good news
is we can even produce oxytocin through
a webcam so research has studied this
thank goodness this is why we all
survived over virginia
for so long right even danica and i
making eye contact with the webcam we
are still gifting each other oxytocin
actually i was trying to do it right at
the end and trying to see if you caught
it but um you taught me a really great
trick um when i was researching actually
it was kind of one of the things that
made me go i need to read this book oh
my god and then i read the book and then
i was like i'd like to talk to you um
was because in an interview you really
don't want to interrupt that's right
really not a great tactic to um keeping
the flow and the respect and and even
listeners they like to hear clean
interviews where it's like question
answer question answer it sounds cleaner
and so i picked it up
when you listening to you about how to
use a cue to
basically get them to stop talking so
that you can and you're about you're
doing it right now you're like uh a
little bit you're kind of like
insinuating that you have something to
say so yeah i was picking that so anyway
so someone will be talking and i'd be
like
like open my mouth right open your mouth
and kind of like almost be like oh you
almost said something but you didn't and
it totally works it's totally it's
totally worried okay so let's talk about
this this is called the fish
open mouth or the fish and you use it
perfectly which is how do you get
someone to stop talking politely right
right so you just did it perfectly which
is the very first one is you literally
open your mouth like a fish
i'll make a sound effect just because we
have listeners
right
that open mouth it just cues someone's
about to say something and they'll wrap
up their thoughts so the open mouth is
the is the first kind of least socially
aggressive one the second one you can do
is a very slight hand up so just i put
my hand up
with a j well with a gesture so i can
like hold my hand up like my palm or i
can even make a gesture like oh wait one
more little thing and i hold my hand up
like i'm holding a little thing
and that just shows you i just want to
add one little tiny thing um and so that
if you hold a hand gesture up people
will realize oh she has something to add
literally it's my hands way of saying i
have just one little little just note i
just want to make right there so you can
try that you can try also the fish and
the hand so
right that's also a good one and if
you're in person you can also do a very
light touch so a light touch on their
hand or a light touch on their arm
that's the most aggressive that's the
most aggressive but sometimes you get
people who are like in their own world
oh yeah and you just lay that delicate
little hand on their forearm or their
hand and you're just kind of saying like
i'm still here have you guys decoded
texting because there's a short textures
the long textures the emoji textures
oh yeah oh yeah okay so we have decoded
one thing which is so fun okay so first
i have a question for you before i
explain the study are you ready sure
of course is it
fun or physically painful for you to add
exclamation points
fun
fun okay so what we found is so this is
research actually out of princeton
university which looked at um
charismatic people so what makes someone
charismatic and what they found was very
simple that highly charismatic people
rank high in two traits warmth and
competence
and these are the most important traits
we're interacting with someone we want
to know can i trust you and can i rely
on you so when we are interacting we are
constantly signaling or cueing warmth
and competence this happens in person on
video on the phone and in text but in
text we're only using one mode of
communication verbal right we get to add
a little bit of imagery if we're using
emojis so
of the cues right we have verbal vocal
nonverbal and imagery imagery is like
the colors we wear ornaments we use what
what's in our backgrounds
so one quick study is i can almost
always
tell how warm or competent someone is
based on their emoji and exclamation
point use
so emojis are highly warm people who add
a lot of emojis or whoop yay fab wow
those are all very warm exclamations and
typically i will highly warn people will
add an exclamation point after every
sentence and then have to remove one
because it's too much exclamation points
yeah sometimes
yeah yeah okay so highly warm by highly
competent folks it's physically painful
for them to add an exclamation point
and for them they prefer data numbers
charts efficiency getting right to the
point they love a period right it's a
complete thought
and so when we do these text audits we
can look and see likely how they are
rated by their peers
based on the number of emojis and
exclamation points versus percents
numbers and periods
wow
all of this stuff makes me wonder i know
because i know that you know you
studying people and their patterns and
you know really decoding people
it really makes me question and wonder
this whole idea of
are we holographic
what is consciousness
are we basically sort of like is the
human body just sort of a patterned code
that some that things come out of it
consciousness may be unique but coming
out of the body through this body and
this human existence and this density it
has a pattern to it because everything
is energy what do you
as i say all that what do you think
about you know what i immediately think
about is consciousness
and ai
yeah
and
if we're talking about cues and i think
i was thinking about this a lot while
writing cues is
could this be used as a manual for
robots
right i mean what what i'm trying to do
and exactly in your words i'm trying to
code
cues that are unconscious sense i'm
trying to break down our behavior which
is all energy into
a database
really and that's what i'm doing right
and that scares me a little bit
yeah because before i think a lot of
people had thought about charisma as
sort of this
energy right charisma it's a thing it's
that feeling that magnetism you get from
someone is that and
yeah x factor exactly they have it or
they don't have it
in this book i take a stand which you
know i was a little bit scared to do but
it's how i feel
which is i don't think charisma is an x
factor i think it's a formula 100 i
think it's a formula
so if charisma is a formula and anyone
can learn it
and we can use specific cues like a
recipe and that is the metaphor i use
when i teach cues is
charisma is a recipe and everyone's cake
tastes a little bit different so you can
sprinkle in the warmth that you like a
little sweeter versus a little bit more
savory like everyone has a little bit of
flavor but really it's a formula
isn't that how we could also create ai
or artificial intelligence to literally
use it as like a database to pull from
could we create
ai influencers who literally just use
this database
to tweet out share and create videos
with the right body language cues vocal
cues and number cute where we're like
yeah charismatic
so i think the answer is kind of yes i
don't know if it was a yes or no
question but
yes i think that
i'm trying to quantify an it factor or
an energy to say this is attainable but
it means anyone could attain it
or anything
anything could obtain it
so do you believe then that an ai like
a.i could be just like a human industry
indistinguishable and
could be called human
yeah i think that
here's one little quick study about
literally robots okay
this and this was like yep it's i think
that they could be described as human in
the sense of
very simple study they showed people
pictures of robots like little graphics
of robots
and in one image the robot's head was
straight up and down and in the next
image the robot had a slight head tilt
so slightly laterally to the side
they asked people to rate the robot on
human tendencies
the simple head tilt made people ascribe
more human tendencies including cuteness
to the head tilt that was the only
difference between the two graphics
that is because all they did was add one
human cue
to the robot a head tilt is a universal
sign of openness
when i'm trying to hear something better
i tilt my head to expose my ears dogs do
this as well actually yep i i tilt my
head to expose my ear and so we know
that if i'm listening to you and you do
this really well as an interviewer is
when i say something interesting you
might tilt your head side to side to say
oh i hear that it's literally you
non-verbally showing you hear me so just
adding a head tilt to a graphic of a
robot makes us feel the robot is
listening to us
what could be more human
okay well then what are we
oh
and next time on our episode
i mean if that's true then what are we
and especially i think i've heard you
say that you don't believe in psychics
and that kind of stuff so like if you
don't
that's telling me perhaps that you you
know the quantum field is not something
that
it's
the cue
that passes through the field to you but
not actually meaning like you know what
about the idea about you think you might
not believe so much and you think about
someone and then they call you and that
that's psychic or someone walks into a
room and no you can't see them yet at
all but you feel them you because
because there's no cue there for it so i
feel like what you're saying is that
there has to be some kind of interaction
to create
the cue connection
that yes that is exactly how i feel when
i say i don't believe in psychics what i
mean is i think that our cues are so
powerful
that someone could walk into a psychics
office or a fortune teller's office
and by pheromone cue gesture wrinkle
patterns and we won't even get into that
but i think again our wrinkle patterns
can tell us about our personality the
size of our hands the shape of our face
a really good psychic is actually just a
really good q reader
so that's what i mean is that i think
that our cues are so powerful that we
can tell
so much about someone by just even
hearing them but especially looking at
them
now having someone you think about
someone having them call
that's maybe my next set of research
interesting right okay then what are we
we'll finish it up here and just be like
what are we then
i think we are beings
desperate to feel not alone
the whole reason that we send cues is to
desperately signal to others i want to
be loved i want to be accepted i want
you to be a being with me and so all we
are i think are these cute beings that
are just looking for other people to
read and mirror their cues so we don't
have to feel alone i love that
thank you
maybe you're right who knows we might
have to die to figure it out and if we
die we'll figure it out but there's
nothing else
i think i can think about and i gotta i
got and by the way if we ever did
another episode i'll bring my fortune
teller statements for you to try to
prove the fortune teller stuff for you
yeah i'm super into that so i'd be very
fascinated and i'm open i mean my level
of openness is very high so
i would love for you to prove me wrong
or try
let's do it let's do it all right oh my
god thank you so much you're fascinating
and your books i mean captivate was
amazing and i can't wait to read cues
and i'm just be going to be a q a
machine or at least a q reading machine
a cute reading machine well thank you so
much i was so excited when i saw that
you were reading captivate it just made
my month and so i'm just honored to be
here for everyone who's listening to
thank you for being open-minded with us
and i'm just so grateful so thanks for
having me yeah thank you
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today i hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the subscribe button